Hello, and welcome to this
episode of Google Developers
Live.
I'm Sarah Maddox from the Google
Maps Developer Relations team,
and I'm going to show
you how to use a map
padding with the Google
Maps Android API.
Let's say you have an
application that has a map
and you want to add
a sidebar to the map,
but you don't want to hide the
map UI controls or the Google
logo.
Let's see what
happens if you add
a sidebar without
adding map padding.
This little demo app has
a sidebar on the right.
And as you can see the
find my location control
is at the top right, but
it's obscured by the sidebar.
And similarly the
map zoom controls
are at the bottom right, and
they're completely hidden.
So what I've done
with this application
is add a button called padded.
And if I touch
the padded button,
the application
calls a method which
adds 30 pixels of map padding on
the right hand side of the map.
So you can see that the
UI controls are now nicely
displayed slightly to
the left of my sidebar.
The map still takes
up the entire view
but the user controls
and the gestures
behave as if they're
only using up
the smaller, visible
portion of the map.
So I'm going to tap the
find my location control.
And you can see that
the little blue location
indicator is nicely positioned
in the center of the map.
It's taken map
padding into account.
Now if I touch the
normal button-- which
removes map padding from
my map-- and then touch the
find my location
button again, you'll
see that the location
indicator has moved slightly
to the right, and it
seems to be off center.
And that's because it's taking
the whole map into account
instead of just the
visible portion.
OK, I'm going to touch
Sydney and position
the center of the
math in Australia
so that there's a nice
lot of blue sea around.
And that means that you
can see the Google logo
at the bottom left
of the screen.
Now it's worth noting that
your application needs
to show the Google logo.
If it hides the
Google logo then it's
not in compliance with the terms
of services of the Google Maps
APIs.
So if you need to add UI
controls at the bottom left
of your map, map
padding is a good way
to make sure that the
Google logo appears.
OK, let's take a
look at the code.
It's very simple, use the
Google Map set padding
method to add padding
around the edges of the map.
The method takes four parameters
to determine the padding
on the left, top,
right, and bottom edges.
And the parameter names are easy
to remember-- left, top, right,
and bottom.
Camera updates, such as
re-centering the map,
will automatically take
care of the padding,
so you don't need to
calculate the offset yourself.
And you can dynamically change
map padding at any time,
the details are in
the documentation.
Also, take a look at the
Google Maps API Demo App
that's shipped with the
Google Play services.
Here's a link to the
documentation about the demo
app.
It has a more complex example
than the one I've shown you.
For example, it allows
you to add some animation
to slide you sidebar in and out.
The padding demo is called
Visible Regions in the demo app
menu.
Thank you, and I hope you've
enjoyed this video from Google
Developers Live.